with almost 500 sessions and X 2018 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see don't get
fished authentication best practices
then stay tuned because here's the
rewind listen nobody actually likes
passwords they're hard to remember easy
to lose and don't protect us all that
well not to mention people are really
bad at picking passwords too I mean just
look at the most popular passwords in
2015 not very hard to guess are they
have you used one of these if not I bet
some of the people you're trying to
protect are using them right now and
2018 doesn't really get much better
maybe we shouldn't be trusting people to
keep password safe at all turns out they
aren't very good at resisting phishing
attempts it's especially easy to get
someone to fall prey to a phishing
attack with a false sense of urgency
such as a fake your account is at risk
email then somebody will spend less time
checking for signs of a fake site and
just rush to complete the form to help
keep you and your people safe Google
will stop these login attempts
automatically when we notice the pattern
deviates from your normal behavior but
it's not perfect this problem is better
suited to a hardware and software
solution and Google has some ideas to
make the password both safer and less
critical to the login process to start
adding any second factor is better than
not at all
many people use a one-time password
already and that is a security
improvement but these are still fishable
especially via SMS and the physical fobs
that give you a six digit code are
expensive and fragile besides if you've
seen that friend carrying 10 or 20 fobs
on a necklace just to get access to the
various systems they use at work you can
see how it doesn't scale we prefer
security key as a second layer of
defense in front of your account the
keys use open cryptography standards
similar to public key encryption and are
physical devices like this which you
register to your account and use to
prove that you are you when you're
logging in the security key does two
important things
one it tells the server that a person
actually sat at the keyboard for this
login because you have to touch the key
to activate it so we can stop automated
script based attacks - it goes through a
challenge response handshake with the
server and will only complete a login
with the appropriate back-end so if you
go to a cleverly disguised phishing site
that tries to steal your login
credentials the security key will fail
to authenticate you we've mandated
security keys for all Google employees
and they've shown tremendous
effectiveness at preventing account
compromised we also see a faster time to
log in so we're actually making people
more efficient and more secure at the
same time and we see fewer support
incidents with security keys compared to
one time password fobs lucky for you the
exact same capabilities can be yours G
suite administrators can enable or
require security keys for accounts in
your domain we highly recommend security
keys to help you secure your high-value
accounts including executives and domain
super admins to learn more about how you
can use security keys how Google secures
employee accounts and to see an exciting
new kind of security key check out the
link in the description below for the
full talk thanks for watching subscribe
to the cloud YouTube channel for more
next rewind videos
you
[Music]